good afternoon everyone
good day good evening wherever you're
joining us from
i'm ann kirf i'm the dean of the yale
school of nursing and i'm really
delighted to welcome each of you to the
global health
conversation series sponsored by the
yale institute for global health yigh
this series is a venue for our community
to learn from and connect with
innovative leaders in global health in
addition to y igh we are indebted to the
george herbert walker jr lecture in
international studies
at the whitney and betty macmillan
center for international area studies at
yale
for co-sponsoring the series including
today's event
i'm so pleased to be able to welcome the
over 700 people who've registered for
today's event including
faculty students and alumni of yale
university
colleagues at the un development program
and at permanent missions to the un in
new york
and the general public it's a pleasure
to be with you all today
as we are all seeing more and more and
experiencing earth's life-sustaining
ecosystems are being undermined
threatening human health other species
health development and survival
while we have seen increases in the
lifespan and declines in child mortality
and notable reductions in poverty these
advances are being undermined by climate
change
deforestation loss of arable land
freshwater depletion ocean acidification
and pollution
today's conversation will focus on the
critical issue of planetary health
which stresses the urgent need to better
understand relationships between these
global scale impacts and population
health
and to develop strategies and policies
to lessen these impacts
repair natural systems and maintain the
planet
in a state that is conducive to optimal
population health
planetary health has become an
increasingly important area at yale with
a variety of initiatives across the
campus
through yigh we have recently launched a
planetary health network
which brings together faculty members
from across the university who are
passionate about planetary health
to collaborate on research projects and
knowledge sharing initiatives
please look to the yhh website if you're
interested in learning more or joining
this network
in addition the university has launched
the planetary solutions project which
draws on yale's repository of
world-class knowledge
innovation and leadership to address
human-caused environmental change and
crises
building on this effort we are so
pleased to have with us today
akim steiner administrator of the un
development program
for nearly three decades administrator
steiner has been a global leader on
sustainable development
climate resilience and international
cooperation
to formally introduce administrator
steiner i'll now turn to my colleague dr
laron nelson
hello everyone my name is lauren nelson
and i am the associate dean for global
affairs
and planetary health at the yale school
of nursing
today i am pleased to be joined by my
fellow co-moderator dr robert dubrow
professor of epidemiology at bl school
of public health
and faculty director of the yale center
on climate change and health
thanks for being here today rob dr
dubrow and i are also the co-leads of
the yale institute for global health's
planetary health network
and we are excited that today's event
will spark new ideas and interests
on this critically important issue it is
my pleasure to introduce today's
distinguished guest
ochem steiner administrator of the
united nations development program
over his entire career he has worked
tirelessly to champion sustainable
development
green economy and international
cooperation
and has been a vocal advocate of the
2030 agenda
and the sustainable development goals
administrator steiner has served across
the united nations system
looking at global challenges through the
sustainable development lens between
2006 and 2016
he led the united nations environment
program the un's leading environmental
authority
that sets the global environmental
agenda
in 2017 he was elected by the united
nations general assembly
to head the united nations development
program which works with 170 countries
to support poverty eradication
and inclusive society arkenstein had
previously held other notable positions
including director of oxford martin
school
director general of the international
union for the conservation of nature
and secretary general of the world
commission on dams
in december of last year the united
nations development program launched its
human development report 2020
which lays out a stark choice for world
leaders
take bold steps to reduce the immense
pressure
that is being exerted on the environment
and the natural world
or humanity's progress will stall
the report argues that as people and
planet enter
an entirely new geological epoch the
anthropocene
or the age of humans it is time for all
countries to redesign their paths to
progress
by fully accounting for the dangerous
pressures humans put on the planet
and dismantle the growth imbalances of
power and opportunity
that prevent change during today's
conversation i look forward to
discussing the reports and the important
issue of planetary health
please join me in welcoming
administrator steiner
thank you thank you very much um dean
curt um
dear president nelson therefore the bro
um
i assume that this is where i simply
take off and and jump in unless somebody
stops me and
let me begin by thanking you all for
this wonderful invitation the
opportunity to spend an
hour and a half with you and some of
your faculty and others who are
interested in this topic of
planetary health and i want to thank
both the dean and president nelson for
a very kind introduction because what um
in a sense prompted i think
us to focus on this issue of planets
uh people and prosperity and planetary
health
has really come into focus particularly
through our world of undp
through the human development report we
published for 2020
and for those of you who may not be so
familiar undp is the united nations
development program it's at the heart of
the un
development system it's the entity that
works in 170 countries on the major
development issues
of our time but there's also an
organization that obviously with the
experience it
assembles from so many different
frontiers of development across the
world
tries to sometimes bring into focus the
challenges and
perhaps the horizons against which we
need to think about the future of
development
and so the topic of planetary health and
the theme of our 2020 human development
report coincide very neatly because they
both
recognize that we are at an inflection
point
and that inflection point comes down to
something very
common sense like um you sometimes have
to wonder why it took us so long to
realize that
human health and environmental health
are inextricably linked
and everybody knows this from a kind of
locational experience
pollution is something that we have
known for hundreds of years
and we know that pollution and
environmental condition
clearly affects human health but over
time we have also begun to realize that
it's not just a locational issue it used
to be an
issue of urban geography to those of you
who maybe have studied geography in your
lives where
if you look particularly in the united
kingdom at the settlement patterns and
urbanization patterns
the wealthy always lived up wind of an
industrial
factory or industrial infrastructure and
the poor live downwind
already there you saw the impact of
pollution
inequality and quality of life including
the impact on health of people
very clearly manifested in a way that
today really has taken on a planetary
dimension
and if i may just fast forward a little
bit and take another example of
pollution
that already 40 years ago began to
preoccupy us
ozone ozone-depleting substances
destroying that very thin
film of ozone the ozone layer around our
planet earth and our recognition that we
had to phase out these ozone-repeating
substances in order to avoid
what was already beginning to be
manifestly a planetary health problem
a hole in the ozone layer increased
number in cancer skin cancers premature
death
and so the toll the numbers and the
empirical evidence
continue to mount about how
environmental not just destruction but
also environmental impacts
clearly were linked to human well-being
fast forward a little bit because
this is a sort of common sense entry
point but today we live in a time and
professor nelson just alluded to it we
have taken this notion of living in the
age of the anthropocene as a way of
trying to reconceptualize
quite how significant the impact of
humans is anthropocene the age of humans
is a simple way of expressing an
immensely complex set of changes and
developments that are underway
but using the term anthropocene and it
is not yet an accepted one
in the geological sense of an age or an
era like the holocene but you know
scientists and bodies are currently
debating
whether indeed the notion of living in
the age of the anthropocene after the
holocene does make sense and what it
really
implies is two things one the nature
and scale of the impact of humans on the
planet has become geologically traceable
we are now the dominant species on this
planet we are changing its atmosphere
its biosphere
we are changing the composition of the
quality of water the quality of air and
and many other elements
that signal to us that this is a
qualitative and quantitatively different
dimension in which we need to think
about the presence of homo sapiens the
human species so to speak on the planet
and to some this is obviously very much
a narrative associated with the doomsday
scenario but let me
very quickly try and counter that notion
yes
it is a way of understanding quite how
significant
our collective impact is on this planet
today
and by implication and by consequence on
future generations
but it is also a way of trying to focus
on the fact that we have choices
never in human history before have we
had the wealth
the science the knowledge the technology
the possibilities of choosing different
pathways and therefore
living in the age of the anthropocene is
not inevitably a doomsday scenario
on the country it is an era of choices
and choices with consequences that are
intergenerational
now very quickly fast forward to how we
have measured human progress because
part of the planetary health notion
people
planet prosperity has basically been
this very simplistic way that
essentially it is through economics
through money through wealth through
gross domestic product
per capita gdp that we have spent the
better part of 100 years of measuring
human progress
human development and it was that that
led
in about 30 years ago undp to challenge
this notion that
the best way to measure progress in
development was to do so
through this economic narrow lens that's
when the human development report was
first conceived of by
very uh inspiring and forward-looking
economists uh professor ahmadiyya sen
mabu will hack and many others who came
up with the human development index in
its simplest form it was a way of
expanding the lens
introducing health and education as
additional
parameters for measuring human progress
and very deeply rooted in the notion of
capabilities
capabilities to succeed as a human being
now we still as a world continue to
measure progress
almost exclusively through this gdp lens
and it is one that has led us
essentially to the point where today you
could argue
we are truly missing the point
namely that people planet and prosperity
have a far more intricate relationship
and decisions need to
evolve far more rapidly in order to
ensure that
human well-being and the corollary of
planetary well-being of planetary health
need to be managed in sync we need to
measure progress differently we need to
take different decisions and this is why
in 2020
our human development report shows the
new frontier the next frontier and human
development as being related precisely
to this issue
we introduced a new planetary adjusted
human development index that tried to
capture
the health of the planet through the
impacts that we're having as humans
combined with the traditional human
development index it's an experimental
index we have put it out there for the
world to consider what we believe it is
perhaps
the best way in which we can currently
give expression to this notion of
planetary health and its links to human
health
now in its consequences and i'll end
with that um
is the simple recognition and bobby
kennedy once put it very simply he says
that gdp measures everything in short
except
that which makes life worthwhile and
it is that search for a way in which we
can take
a common sense realization an intuitive
understanding that underpins that notion
of planetary health
and translated into measurable and
empirically validated foundations
because that is how we make public
policy that is how we trade off
choices in different contexts and much
of what undp
does today not least in the midst of a
covet 19 crisis is to help countries
conceive of a development pathway out of
this crisis building forward better
now it's easily proclaimed it is easily
stated
how do you do it you have to make policy
choices about
the fiscal policy systems taxation
systems because here is the first
distortion
our markets are not operating rationally
they subsidize things that harm us and
essentially harm
ultimately prosperity and
tax the good decisions that people take
this is
the taxation system of the early 21st
century
we tax labor through high income taxes
but we hardly tax pollution
this is not rational in this age and it
is fundamental to understanding why we
have come to a point
where planetary health has become such a
challenge we need to look also at
the way that inequality intersects with
planetary health
the fact that research showed us um some
years ago
that when lead was still being put into
petrol with
the argument that essentially that was a
price we had to pay for
affordable mobility it was the poor who
lived by the roadsides of the main
highways that were most affected by
lead in petrol and it was the children
of poor people
who had far higher levels of lead in
their
bodies than children of wealthier
families because they lived further away
from the highways
they had gardens they lived in leafy
suburbs simple
illustrations of how inequality and
environmental impacts and human health
interface let me end by just saying
because i i look forward very much to
the questions and the discussions that
we have
that in the world of the 21st century in
thinking about the future of development
which is so much the focus of undp's
work today
and that of the united nations system in
helping a very
unequal world and a very stressed world
to find together a better way forward
using the sustainable development goals
that many of you will have heard not
as some metric but rather as a compass
on which we can together
address a reset a recalibration of the
yardsticks of human progress
and ultimately enable us to realize a
very simple
fact prosperity is about
people and not about money we measure
prosperity in monetary terms but
actually what we really mean
is are people able to fulfill their
aspirations in life
and so to demonetize to some extent not
to ignore that dimension but to
demonetize it to some extent and to
complement it
with an understanding of how much people
therefore also depend
on the planet for their well-being and
how
the way we consume and produce and
exercise our economic choices
ultimately shapes the nature of
our planet and its ability to sustain us
is at the heart of rethinking people
planet and prosperity in our age thank
you so much and president nelson back to
you
hi so actually this is robert dubrow so
it's back to me
um so yeah thanks uh administrator
steiner for
some very insightful comments um
and building on those comments i wanted
to ask the first question so
uh i and and um dr nelson will ask a
couple of questions and then we're going
to open it up to the audience
so my the first question is and you you
dealt
to some degree with this already so i
was wondering if you could elaborate
um what is the scope and scale
of human pressures on the planet and
importantly
social imbalances and inequality
contribute to the problem
well i gave you a couple of parameters
already but just to
give you a sense um let me for instance
give you a couple of more
indicators of of the scale for example
if you realize that the total mass of
things humans have made like buildings
roads bottle tops plastic bags
now exceeds the total mass of all living
things
on our planet it gives you one sense of
the anthropogenic
impact we have had of the sheer scale of
what we have
and there are some wonderful other
analogies about chicken bones for
example a few people realize that
chickens are
the most mass-produced consumable
livestock in the world
and um you know if you were to add up
all the chicken bones ever consumed
extraordinary mountains would be found
on planet earth
um but let me also give you a sense of
quite
how dark some of these statistics have
become particularly in the last 100
years
we have destroyed well over 50 percent
of the world's wetlands in just
half a century in the name of progress
in the name of development in the name
of
um you know useless environmental um
assets that are not being put into
productive use we have done most of the
world's rivers with the argument that
the ingenuity human ingenuity of
building dams to produce electricity
irrigate lands always outweighs the
ingenuity of nature that
has given us these extraordinary
riverine and hydrological ecosystems
that
have such extraordinary functions um in
our planetary
context but also in terms of humanity's
survival
and you know water is another very good
um
example and metaphor through which to
look at the kind of situations we have
created for ourselves
in a country like australia today the
murray darling basin is a river basin
where most of the water
is now traded it is traded and it is no
longer used for farming
but in fact farmers trade their water
rights
to the urban city municipalities in
order to ensure that
these municipalities have enough water
to provide drinking water
to the urban population we are reaching
in so many
aspects in also parts of the world
planetary boundaries it's a concept that
um you know has emerged in recent years
and i think provides us with a very
useful way of understanding
what is the boundary condition after
which you're no longer dealing with the
planets
ingenious systems of producing what we
need to survive in it
but you're depleting the capital stock
so to speak and you're destroying the
capability
of nature to sustain us and another
horrendous statistic is that you know
roughly 70
7-0 of the world's wildlife may have
been lost in the past 50 years
add to that climate change that we are
just a few years away from
passing the point at which carbon
emissions accumulate in the atmosphere
are going to move beyond the point of no
return
in terms of a 1.5 degree warming
scenario i.e
for generations probably hundreds of
years people will no longer have even
the option
of trying to get back to a world that
maybe has warming below 1.5 degrees
no it is then essentially a reality
out of control these are some of the
parameters within which i think we can
begin to
you know comprehend the scope and scale
of change and that is why
i often say we are the first generation
of the anthropocene
where truly we have begun to understand
that we are changing the atmosphere
and the biosphere on this planet
inconceivable to our grandparents
a reality and a very stark one to our
children
already administrator steiner
i wasn't prepared for that chicken bone
example
i have to say i feel personally
responsible for that particular
challenge but
you know in the human development 2020
report
it it was stark how it laid out
how calamities are really the product of
this
you know concept of people and planet
being out of sync
talk to us about how cover 19 is an
example
of this imbalance between human and
planetary health and
also what have we learned from it and
how can we be prepared for
the next pandemic calamity
you know to me personally the pandemic
has been
a stark reminder of something that maybe
20 years ago really led me to
focus on the link between environment
and development or environment and human
well-being
in ways that maybe when i was studying
at university
you know as a development economist had
not really been at the forefront of my
mind
that was the realization that in so many
ways
at this point in time we are confronted
with choices
that yes in some respects
still must be based on imperfect
knowledge
but this is where i sometimes have often
struggled with the debates about climate
change because this this notion that
we will only decide to do something when
we have perfect knowledge
goes against everything that we have
learned in human history
and whoever in life has the privilege of
having perfect knowledge and foresight
in order to take a decision and i think
it is
that conundrum in which we find
ourselves namely
the necessity to act with sufficient
information to
make us more cautionary about what comes
next
and yet not having a guarantee that the
solutions we have
will work covet 19 first of all is a
perfect illustration
of the latter so many decisions had to
be taken in a number of days
so often we got it wrong so often we
paid a price which in hindsight you ask
yourself how could this have happened
the second big lesson is i think we need
to realize that preparedness is not a
luxury
and you know if you just take the
numbers today um
you know the the cost of this pandemic
alone
is about 500 times as much as a pandemic
prevention
measures uh combination would have cost
us if we
had taken them in time and probably that
number is an underestimate
because we did not take this thing
seriously despite the fact that we had
sars we had ebola we had
enough illustrations about how um
zoonotic diseases can jump from
the animal kingdom so to speak into
human bodies this is not something that
has happened for the first time to us
it has happened to us time and again in
history
but now we are in the 21st century and
here i think there is the added
dimension that with
travel with global trade but also with
the interdependence that we have built
up
we are so much more vulnerable
physically economically
and socially and i think it is this
combination of
realities that i think is making us all
reflect far more deeply
about what will life be like
following covet 19 and let's always
remind us that we are still in the midst
of this crisis
um yes some countries are now
vaccinating ahead of others but you know
just the vaccination
dilemma is already an illustration of
how difficult we are finding it to act
as a global community when we know that
we're going to lose this battle against
the virus if we cannot vaccinate
everyone
and yet look at the statistical reality
of who is getting vaccinated right now
and who is not
this is one of the illustrations of what
we mean by
acting against our own interests this is
not rational
and this is the price we are paying for
not taking the notion of resilience
seriously
and the relationship between nature and
human well-being
is not only you know i think illustrated
in this instance by a virus that has
moved into our lives in such a brutal
way
it is the realization that so much of
what has happened in the last 50 to 100
years in particular because that's where
all the curves went up exponentially
deforestation pollution destruction of
wetlands
etc soil fertility that is being lost
ocean acidification these are all
drivers
of greater environmental
change and ultimately vulnerability
and i think the more we are able to see
these systems interact the more we
recognize
that we are actually entering into an
age of extreme vulnerability
and even more so of a lack of
preparedness
and therefore resilience becomes more
elusive
rather than something that we have built
you know at a moment in time
when science technology and wealth for
that matter
would have suggested otherwise
um yeah thank you administrator steiner
um
i wanted to turn to um
how we actually affect change so
the question is how can we encourage
policy makers and legislators
to consider the impacts of planetary
health
how can we incentivize positive change
and innovations at all levels at the
local
domestic regional and global again at
the
risk of oversimplification but you know
as a first
starter to to respond to your question
i think there are a number of drivers
that ultimately will determine how a
society
makes choices and the first one
has to be informed and empowered
citizens i think whether
even if you're living in a more
autocratic regime
or you're living in the ideal democracy
which probably is
also an elusive aspiration perhaps in
the minds of many
um informed and empowered citizens
are ultimately the base upon which you
can
both transact and develop different
policy choices
and i think one of the great things
about time is that if you
you know even if i look at the
generations that are now coming
after us kids who are five ten fifteen
year
old today they live in an age where
information
and the ability to understand more about
what is happening to the world not just
around you where we
perhaps who grew up still in a very
isolated family or rural community might
have found ourselves in the 60s or even
70s
today for many children around the world
understanding that there is a world out
there
and that they are part of it comes so
much more naturally and i think therein
lies
one of my reasons for being an optimist
because i do believe that
informed and empowered citizens do act
differently and
you know just take the the example of um
fridays for future and here we are in a
moment in time where 13 14 15 year olds
have essentially taken charge of
the most central challenge of our time
climate change
um not only has it you know opened the
eyes and
opened conversations in virtually you
know every country in a different way
they are leading the debate and they are
leading it with a clarity of purpose and
understanding
that um i must say i'm sometimes envious
when i
compare my daily life sitting in united
nations conferences
and looking at how we sometimes try to
transact
despite what we know but this is the
second part and here lynn lies i think
a critical understanding our economies
are foundational to what sustains us it
drives our ability
to you know ultimately have employment
have food access to electricity
health care and so on so how our economy
sends signals and in which direction it
encourages
consumption production or discourage it
is critical
one taxation and fiscal policy you know
we still live in an age where as i
mentioned earlier on
we subsidize things that we know
based on science and evidence are
harmful
but because of legacy interests because
of the inertia in our economies because
of
economic power being vested in perhaps a
few who have a lot to gain from the
status quo we are not acting on
knowledge
we are keeping an economic system going
that um essentially has to shift whether
you call it a green economy
a more equitable economy
that social contract in which
governments essentially
shape the economic rules of the game
needs to evolve and fiscal policy
taxation um
you know fossil fuel subsidies these are
just
some egregious examples of where we need
to focus on and it ultimately comes down
to
how financial markets will view the
future
financial markets i think are often
viewed as
this sort of you know untameable you
know dinosaur or monster
but really financial markets at their
simplest are fairly mercenary
where you can make money you will go and
make money so
what is it that makes it so difficult
for us at this crucial moment in time
to also incentivize financial markets to
invest differently
to invest in tomorrow's economy rather
than in yesterday's economy and here is
the great debate of our time
how much does the state how the
government step in how much do
governments also compensate for the fact
that
markets are not very good at transacting
in the interests of the public good it's
not that there are automatically at
cross purposes with the public good
but the public would clearly done right
now demands that we get to a zero
net zero emissions well by 2050 and
there is no one who has yet proven to me
that markets left to their own devices
will do this in time which is why
regulatory and public policy
signals need to accelerate the pace of
change
give rise to new markets and frankly
speaking we're already seeing it happen
where we
put the right measures in place
renewable energy we're in the midst of a
renewable energy revolution
it is transforming our energy systems
and hundreds of years of relying on
fossil fuels
are probably you know 20 to 30 years
down the line of becoming really a
anachronism
and that's how quickly we can shift for
example on something like fossil fuels
the lifeblood of our
20th century 19th century 18th century
economies
and by 2050 i guarantee you access to
electricity to energy for most people on
the planet
will be far less of a problem than it
has ever been in human history
and that is the kind of economic shift
that we need
so encouraging policy makers and
legislators begins with citizens
empowered and informed citizens it then
involves governments
and it recognizes how central the rules
of the game
of our markets are in driving change or
preventing change
administrator steiner i have to say your
your perspective as an
optimist definitely comes through in the
human development report i
i i recall uh
the language about humans as agents
right humans as people
that have the power and the capacity to
uh to produce better for themselves
and that the goal of human development
really is about facilitating the
conditions
to support human freedom and autonomy
and
you know as someone who leads an agency
that works with
170 countries around the world for
poverty eradication and
inclusive society i want to ask you
how can we create strong partnerships
and collaborations across the world to
fulfill the promise of
the climate agenda while also
as we face social economic these
socio-economic crises
that has been triggered by the copa 19
pandemic what are your thoughts on that
if you're telling me just a brief remark
on agency i think it is a very
critical um aspect of
the 2020 human development report
because
you know it's very easy for many of us
in today's world you know
the fourth industrial revolution world
the digitalization world artificial
intelligence everybody talking about
systems
complexity to feel disempowered
and i think this is a very dangerous
narrative
to pursue and that's why in the human
development report
we try to put so much attention on this
notion of
agency the ability to choose
the capabilities to make choices that
are different from those that are simply
handed down to us and choices really
matter
and um you know in a recent ted talk i i
use the analogy that you know systems
don't change systems people change
systems and it is very much with that
um philosophy over that paradigm let's
say
in mind that we approach these
you know epochal choices that we have to
make right now
and you asked me about partnerships um
the easiest answer is you know the more
we work together the easier it will be i
mean this is the foundational principle
of the united nations
in 1945 on the ashes of the second world
war
and you know having learned the bitter
lesson of what happens to a
world that is capable of
self-destruction even more so after the
second world war
finding the the
both the place the space and the ability
to
work together despite our differences
clearly is
at the heart of any notion of
partnership and i would begin when we
you know have a challenge such as
climate change to remind ourselves that
with all the justified criticism of
30 years of climate negotiations you
know from
the rio 1992 summit through the
copenhagen
climate convention summit into the paris
agreement and yes here we are in the
year 2021 and time is still running out
but at the same time just imagine for a
moment that we didn't have the ipcc
over 30 years ago that kind of you know
rescued science from the dictum of
national policy and national interest
that allows scientists to speak to the
world independently about
what we knew and what we didn't know
what was happening to our planet
if you then think of the climate
convention do you think we would have
been worse off
or better off if not every year for the
past i think it is now
25 or 26 years the climate convention
essentially brought all these countries
around the table once a year
in the limelight of international
attention
and showed up the world's nations and
leaders for
what they were doing or not doing i
think we reached paris in 2015
because the public saw how
much was not being done and so that
partnership
uncomfortable as it is even in a very
political world of a
g2 world you know china and the us uh or
europe and africa
you know you can find many reasons to
look at
the world being very divided and yet we
have
a paris agreement we have a pathway to
raising ambition levels every five years
and hopefully a possibility of aligning
where the world is acting
was where science is telling us since
years we should have acted
so this is one way of thinking about
partnership the other one may be between
public sector and private sector and you
know frankly speaking
anybody who thinks that the private
sector does not
or is not needed as a partner in this um
enterprise of challenging
uh of addressing the challenge of
climate change loss of biodiversity
simply overlooks the fact that most of
the things that happen
in our daily lives are transacted not
through governments not through
public sector budgets but through the
private sector
and the private sector also is not
always corporate
multinational giant companies private
sector is the small scale farmer it's
the corner shop owner
it's the startup enterprise it's the
people who produce most of the world's
food today small small-scale farmers
produce over 70 percent of the food we
consume on the planet
so the private sector is essentially
that extraordinary diverse domain
that we need to bring along that we need
to incentivize
with our consumer choices with our
public policies with our laws
in order to be part of the solution
rather than part of the problem and that
is perhaps the greatest shift
in thinking of our time because remember
milton friedman it's not so long ago
that the credo the religion of economic
correctness was companies have to think
about their shareholders and nothing
else
we have come a long way and we have paid
a heavy price for the time we took to
come this long way
but i think we are in many ways at a
point in time
where the markets of the future on the
one hand will drive new enterprises and
businesses
and where the costs of being rooted in
the legacy economy
will simply become prohibitive and
stranded assets suddenly
become a very stark reality so that is
perhaps um
a way of answering partnerships from
multiple perspectives
thank you yeah thanks administrative
steiner so now we're getting
some questions from the audience so i
have a question here
actually you mentioned world war ii um
so the question is
i wonder if administrator steiner could
talk about a fourth p
the young people planet and prosperity
that of peace could he elaborate on the
relationship between climate change and
conflict
and the importance of building peace
while also addressing climate change
a very appropriate question and in fact
earlier today i was co-chairing with my
colleague filippo grande and the
director general
of humanitarian affairs of the eu the
syria pledging conference
here is a conflict 10 years old
unimaginable suffering and tragedy
its spillover effects into neighboring
countries such as
lebanon jordan and turkey who are
hosting millions of refugees and
at the moment in time where their own
economies are imploding i mean you have
all seen the news about lebanon
so here is one example of how peace
is not only a humanitarian catastrophe
it is also a major setback in
developmental terms and the same applies
for
so many countries in conflict yemen in
which undp and the united nations family
has now been working for a number of
years almost seven years
in another protracted conflict we
estimate that
yemen has lost somewhere between 20 to
25 years of its development
in these six years just to give you a
sense of the setback that that conflict
causes
now many of us have heard and i think
will not be surprised that
if climate change really begins to
affect
you know many of the things that we take
for granted
when it rains when we're able to have
enough water to plant
floods the other extreme but also
temperature variations sea level rise
extreme weather events the sheer impact
on people and humanity in our economies
that we have seen so often in recent
years here in the united states in the
caribbean
where sometimes a 24-hour event can wipe
out 30 percent of your gdp
this kind of disruption is absolutely
anathema to
peaceful societies and peaceful
development that doesn't mean that
people suddenly turn on one another
because of a disaster
but if we allow these pressures to
continue and if we do not prepare for
them
then it is quite clear that we will see
many more conflicts arising whether it
is
upstream downstream water sharing
countries on river basins
whether it is um you know pastoralists
who have to essentially change
their annual migrations with their
livestock and are increasingly clashing
with sedentary farming communities
whether it is the waves of migrants who
essentially see no future in their
countries
and are you know at the risk of their
own lives moving into other parts of the
world whether it is central america to
north america whether it is you know
africa to europe these are the kinds of
disruptions that very quickly when
governance systems don't work well
when societies are prepared give rise to
tensions to conflict to radicalization
to extremism
and a very vicious circle unfolds and i
think another
live illustration of this drama is what
is playing out in the sahel region
probably for the better part of the last
20 to 30 years
and if you look forward unless we truly
step in and get to the root causes of
this disruption
we will see a great deal more conflict
and the absence of peace so it is in my
mind very appropriate that
we are seeing increasingly in the united
nations the link established between
climate change broader environmental
change
and peace and security environmental
change
is threatening international or human
security
there is no doubt in my mind the
question is
can we find a 21st century collective
response
that is not simply rooted in 20th
century or
simply geopolitical conflicts and
competitions
if that is the driving force then indeed
you will continue to witness what you
often see right now
in the security council in international
fora
the inability of governments to provide
collective leadership and partnership
thank you we we have actually many more
questions in the
q and a chat then we're going to be able
to proceed to answer
administrator steiner so uh professor du
brown i will select ones that we think
will be
uh most interesting for you so here's
the next one
uh will you talk a little bit more about
the intersection of environmental
justice
and planetary health with other systems
of oppression
that disproportionately impact identity
groups
for example the plight of gullah gichi
land
sustainability in the gulagichi quarter
of the united states the gullah gucci
are
people who are descendants of slaves
who've
lived along the south south carolina
and south georgia coastal areas and i
think that land is
this drama was seizing the land for
development so this person is asking
uh can you talk a little bit more about
how those
justice and planetary health systems
intersect
thank you for this question it is one
that you know
takes up a significant amount of time
in my thinking that i think of many of
us who work in undp because
whether it is through um the reality of
race
whether it is through poverty and wealth
whether it is through the
gender lens inequalities
amplify the impacts of
the kinds of changes environmental
changes and impacts that i have
described i
earlier mentioned just the example of
lead and air pollution and how you know
just
by virtue of your income your children
very often would be worse affected
because of where you had to live
now race clearly introduces um
in many societies another dimension
of either discrimination or simply of
inadvertently being more vulnerable more
exposed to
to the impacts of change now i don't
know the particular example that
um the questioner raised just now
but clearly reyes has um played a party
in the united states for instance um
most dramatically illustrated during
covet 19
but if you also look at the basic health
data and health statistics
across the country such as the united
states but indeed other countries as
well
more often than not there is a parameter
there is a pattern
in which racial differentiation allows
you to recognize
very differential impacts and so i think
understanding the environmental impacts
which are often transacted in terms of
scientific
indicators and indices they need to be
complemented
by um let's say more social
criteria because it allows us to see not
just the physicality
of what we're talking about but the
social reality
and that's where the notion of justice
becomes so real
now justice is invoked in many ways um
you know there is injustice
that is associated with inequality there
is injustice with discrimination
and there is injustice simply with
negligence
that is often associated with the way
that you know governments and societies
um well at its simplest really care
about all of their citizens
look at our world today um access to
vaccines
is primarily and principally at this
moment in time in the year 2021
a function of how much money you have or
you do not have
this is the 21st century um in which we
are you know
still imprisoned by such a crude way of
um
dealing with something that
fundamentally offends our sense of
justice and fairness
now you can take it very quickly to
climate justice
um for example speaking in an
intergenerational sense
i think to me what fridays for future
did more than anything else
was to remind me of how privileged i am
that i still have the choice to do
something about climate change
while perhaps my sons or their children
will not even have the choice anymore so
here is a fundamental issue of justice
that um again i think defines the way we
need to understand our responsibility to
act
and then there is just transition also
let me give you a dilemma that just a
few weeks ago i
was addressing with um a vice president
and the advisory council of an
african nation which was basically
trying to look at how to build forward
better from covet 19
and it's a country that has discovered
oil that has still gas reserves
and that essentially posed the question
to be so where is the just transition
for us
because for us not drilling and not
exporting
these fossil fuel resources is almost
unexplainable to our citizens so if we
were to take a step back if he were
to actually take a you know leap forward
into the green economy
invest in renewables and perhaps not you
know exploit 50 percent of our fossil
fuel reserves
where is the justice in that when
essentially the industrialized world has
spent 200 years
and the united states just in the last
four years was the world's largest
producer of oil and gas and let us
remind ourselves
the largest carbon dioxide emitter over
the last 200 years taken
you know collectively cumulatively also
was the country that became the largest
oil producer
in in the last four years so if you are
a small african economy
where is the just transition that was
promised as part of this global climate
policy in
this world of today and this is why what
we do in the united nations
whether it's the convention whether it's
undp but it's the united nations
environment program
we try to address this injustice by
finding ways in which a more just
transition becomes possible
and the same can be extrapolated right
back to a local community
if you have grown up in a coal mining
community
and tomorrow somebody tells you you know
it's over
um you're not just dealing with shutting
your mind you may find you know
20 000 jobs for the people you're
essentially killing
a community in the way that it has seen
and identified itself
for decades sometimes it's not just
money that buys
justice here it's a different sense of
what a just transition could mean to to
that community
so let me stop here but i i think it's a
topic that is extremely important
and if we fail or succeed in really
meeting the climate challenge i think it
will largely be as a result
of finding the right answers to this
issue namely what is a just transition
thank you yeah thanks administrator
steiner
um so we have time for one more question
and probably a fairly short answer
um so the question is
uh with the goal of enabling ordinary
people to realize their individual and
personal aspirations themselves
how can science be made more usable
as a tool for use by ordinary people
you know somebody who was never
brilliant at school in the sciences i'm
not sure i'm the best
person to answer that question but um
let me perhaps share with you um
a simple lesson in life and you know
since i now lead an organization that
you know
has 18 000 people to who i'm answer but
to who i also have to sound intelligent
enough to be able to listen to good
scientific advice
i think we need to recognize that um
you know in one person you will never
find everything
whether it is scientific knowledge or
whether it is wisdom
or whether it is perspective for that
matter it is how you bring
people together and how you make
collective thinking collective
intelligence work
and how you're able to listen to science
not as a dictate because science also
really doesn't answer questions it
provides you input and information
in order for us to do what makes us as a
human species so unique
we can process information we can
essentially assimilate facts and then we
make
choices we we can make judgment calls
now sometimes those calls are
almost mathematical and the answer is
very simple two plus two is four
but most of the time in life i think um
the thing that i have learned is that
science provides me with a reference
point
sometimes yes if it's antibiotics it's
also a
very simple treatment but for most of
the things that we are
trying to deal with in terms of
sustainable development you know the
the future of development in this age of
the anthropocene
science is only one dimension of it and
um
i think we have to accept that you know
science is a field that is constantly
growing exponentially just like with
digitalization and technology
and therefore specialization is critical
and
not all of us most of us can be those
specialists
so the question is how do we create
processes in our society
where science continues to inform our
thinking
and doesn't disenfranchise us and this
is not an easy moment because
scientists know a hell of a lot and
certainly know
a great deal more than many of us
but they don't necessarily get the right
to decide for us
so it is both for the scientists to find
ways in which to
engage with society about the knowledge
that they
generate are privileged enough to have
developed on our collective behalf
and it is for us to look for fora in
which we can
transact science and at the end of the
day i go back to where we started this
afternoon which is
we talk about planetary health to some
this sounds incredibly complicated
and yet a lot of it is just common sense
and what we are doing with science is
informing and empowering people to
exercise common sense
with the best possible information at
our disposal
and that kind of slightly shifts the
terms of power here
because there is the temptation for
science to become
almost um a kind of separate universe of
of decision making i think that is not
an interest
either of science nor of society and
i hope that that is perhaps um a way of
approaching an answer it certainly is an
adequate answer to the question
well yeah no that was a great answer uh
thank you
and unfortunately there's this whole
question of science that's
developed that's you know with the
anti-vaccination uh
et cetera that we won't have time to go
to today but it's another important area
related
to science um but um
our time has come to an end so i wanted
to thank you administrator steiner
for a really fantastic conversation
today
i'd also like to thank lauren for
co-monitor moderating
dean kurth for her welcoming remarks
and you the audience for your engagement
and insightful questions
so thank you all for joining us today
and we look forward to seeing you at the
next event
of the yigh global health conversation
series
thank you so much thank you great to
have you